[Music]
i
am pleased to introduce uh colin fay
over here and uh vincent griader who
work at thinkr which is a
uh our consulting services company based
out of france and they're going to talk
about
engineering production grade shiny apps
using golem
so hi everyone so my name is vincent
this is uh colleen
we are both uh hacker and we love to do
a lot of things with r we work at
thinker thinker is a french company
which work on everything are related
we do a lot of training from beginner to
expert
we do a lot of shiny application and we
love to
deploy this shiny application in the
real world for the real
customer needs so we put her into
production
using shiny and we are here today we are
glad
to be here to present you a package
called golem
so before going deeper into golem i
would like to talk
about what is a broad ready software a
product software should
should have metadata to know who
complainer is
should be divided into chunk into small
functions
a production software so we need to be
tested
and you have to provide a list of
requirements
to help to deploy this application
and you have to document
what you did in the software
why do we need this it is to be sure
that this
software will be good enough to go into
production
and that this software will be good
enough to be easily maintainable
so because if you have to create a shiny
application
it could be really easy for everyone to
create a
quick shiny app but if you want to
create a real
big shiny it could it could be a mess
so you have to follow some rules some
steps
to be sure that the process will be okay
to go into production at the end and you
want to follow
um rules to work with many people on the
same project
so because if you want to put your
little shiny app into production
you will have a lot of issue concerning
[Music]
velocity security and maintability
so here comes golem golem is an air
package it's a framework
which will help you to create a prod
ready shiny application
this package is for beginner but also
for experts
so what do you like the most
okay so let's start with this q a what
do you like the most
work on building your data manipulation
visualization
and models or spend 15 minutes checking
that you've correctly copied and pasted
sharing module skeletons
so who's hey
who's b
there is still some
so that's basically the idea behind a
golem
to provide a framework for
doing all this automation and
if you if you are doing the same thing
again and again and again the best way
to do it and the best way to be sure
not to mess up and not to do problem to
have problems is to
use a framework we can say it in many
language and
in even in our using a framework
allows you to to do things more
secure so why golem you
all know the idea that if you have to
copy and paste a piece of code more than
twice
you should write a function and then if
you have to copy and paste
an infrastructure more than twice you
should write a framework
so that's basically the idea with behind
golem is that
we've been building a lot of shiny
applications but we've sent into
production and
in the beginning it's just like you are
building this application then you are
building a second one and then a third
one and another one
but most of the things you do
during the process can be automated
because it's very repetitive it's some
kind of things that you
do again and again so instead of having
to copy and paste from
an old shiny application into a new
application or instead of forgetting the
steps
we have built golems which is a
framework for
a shiny application that
needs to be sent into production
so why usually we're using golem because
we think that
automation is gold that is to say that
if you have to do something
again and again it's better to automate
sets so everything that can be automated
should be automated for example the
copy and passing of shiny module
skeleton is an odd thing
because if you have to copy and paste
from somewhere else you can either have
it i don't know
on a web page you can have it in another
shiny application
you can have it into your notepad and
then just like copying and pasting it
into your application which is
really subject to errors because you can
you have to copy and paste something and
maybe you are missing a line maybe
something like that
so the id is really these kind of things
that can be automated should be
automated
we also think that sharing is caring so
we
we made it open source because we try to
give back to the community so
it's very important for us to share
these good practices that we've been
building for years
and it was important for us to open
sources projects
and also the idea behind this is to
create some kind of collective
intelligence that is to say that if
we are using it
worldwide let's say that if if a lot of
people use
the product we can all build collective
intelligence around it that is to say
people are using it they're giving
feedback they want to improve
with golem is this ideas to build
collective intelligence around how to
send shiny to production
[Music]
so if we go back to what vincent
say about what is a production ready
software it has
metadata it is divided in function
it is tested it lists the requirements
and it's
documented and you think about it
this is what a r package is
so metadata are the description file the
functions are in our folder the tests
are
in the test folder the requirements
are in the namespace and the
documentation goes into
the man and in the vignettes
so the big idea beyond golem so the
first and the central
idea is that a shiny app should be a
package
it's also very helpful to have a package
structure
if you want to talk with it because you
know if you are
sending just a file to your it and say
hey send it to production and they
are going to say yeah but which package
do i need do you have system
requirements
where do you want to deploy it how do
you need things like that
but if you are sending a package a
package can be installed in install the
dependencies
and everything is documented so it helps
deploying the application because
everything is there also
with the documentation with
man and the vignettes it helps
to work on the project on the long run
because if someone
comes and wants to take over the
maintenance
of your shiny application you have
everything documented
with the package structure and that also
means that
if you want to deploy it to your company
so if you want many user to use
your application you can install it as
an our package
and then they can do library your app
and
launch one function that will launch the
application
and the cool thing is that everything
you know about
how to build a package it will also work
with golem so you don't have to learn
something more if you know package
development everything you know about
about it will work so we try to build
on top of everything that exists on all
the cool things like use this
like dev tools like test that
oxygen 2 so everything you know
everything that exists and that works
perfectly
we but we try to build
on top of that so this is the general id
of an application as a package
so how is a column
composed and so if you start a new
project with golem you're going to find
this um this structure so this is the
structure for the upcoming golem version
but
you'll have standard things of a
description in the namespace and the man
and the r folder which are the standard
thing that you'll have in a package
there is an app ui and app server which
are the shiny ui and the shiny server
functions
so everything you have to put in your
server goes there
and everything that you have within your
ui goes into ui so ui server
the run app dot r file
is used to launch your app and
something that is coming in the next
version of golem is the use of
the config package so you have something
called app config.r
that handles the other files of the
column config
yammer so the inst and the man
are standard package folders
and the new thing is this dev
folders of the id is that you have here
four
files so the first is start so it lists
a series of steps you can follow
to build your application so the idea is
that when you start your application
you have this start script that you can
follow so it lists a series of steps
to follow and then you have dev dot r
file which are a series of functions
that you can call
during the process of developing and you
also have a deploy.r
file that contains function to create
the deployment structures and viewrundev
contains is a script that you can launch
to
relaunch your application while you are
developing
so the idea behind this dev folder is to
be sure that you don't forget anything
during the process but it's also to be
sure that you are documented
documenting what you are doing
while developing so you will write
everything that you are doing
and you you have you can keep track of
what you've been doing and of if you are
working like
with someone else you can follow what
they have done and you can see what we
have done
so this is the id behind the dev folder
[Music]
i know that you said that i told you
that
there would be automation so i've been
talking a lot about automation
automation automation
so here comes the part about automation
we've tried to make it easy to do
these repetitive things like creating a
module
creating a css file creating a
javascript handler
creates using a favicon so during the
building process if you want to add a
new module you have a function
that says add module that and what this
function
does is adding a module in the correct
folder
same goes for the css same go for the
javascript handler
and the favicon so if you build a large
scale shiny application you might be
using a lot of modules
so if you just have
if you add to copy and paste all the
modules empty files remove lines and
things like that it can get a little bit
complicated but
with this function you just have to give
your module a name and
play it places the module in the correct
folder so
all these repetitive things are easier
and
as they are automated you are sure that
you're not missing
anything same goes for deployment so
if you want to deploy to any rstudio
product we have
functions to create a file that can be
deployed
to to connect to shiny apps dot io
or to a shiny server and if you want to
create a docker file
out of your package you also have three
functions
that can be used to create this docker
file and
i hope that in the future we can support
more deployment
platforms
so for example we have this template
file
for creating a module
so if i do golem add module
and name i name it my module this will
be create
a file into r mod
so it will create a file in r which is
called
mod underscore my module that's r so you
don't have to
provide the dot r you can but if ever
you forget to
if ever you add it it will be removed at
the end of
the file if and if there is no dot r at
the end it will add it
so this kind of thing also help you
you know not having trouble copying and
vesting things
[Music]
so what this function does is creating
this
skeleton so i removed the top part but
there are
a series of oxygen skeletons for
documenting
your module and
the same thing that i said before is
that
you can have a hard time knowing where
to put your modules and you have to
think about
ids about things like that and
every module skeleton has this little
part
at the bottom that you can copy in your
ui and you can copy a new server so we
are
sure that the id match and things like
that so
you have this skeleton and you don't
have to worry about
whether or not you have the correct
skeleton
and whether or not you have the correct
id
they are just there because they are
scripted and automated
so this is the id behind add modules
[Music]
what's next with uh golem so all the
work in progress and
all the ids are listed on our github
repo so if ever you want to contribute
you're very welcome to do so so as i
said before
we are trying to build like a global
intelligence around
building shiny applications for
production
so if ever you have any id or you want
to contribute
all the work in progress and ids are on
our account
also we what's next is a new release of
golem so i hope
that it will be released in a few weeks
so we've been working a lot since
the summer on a new version of golem so
the docker file creation
is way more smart and is way quicker
than before
we've been integrating the config.jmo
so the config package and future version
of golem so this version
will rely on using config.cml
we've been working on the way it's
documented on the way
modules are created and we've had more
javascript internal
functions so we can hope that it will be
released in a few weeks
what's next what you can do is spread
the word and share the stickers so if
you come to us
we have a series of yeah and full of
golem stickers that will be we would be
happy to share
so if you want to tweet blog posts and
talk to your friends and family about
golem please do
so if you find bug if you want to give
feedback
if you think if you find something that
you think is real is weird
you can open issues if you have id
feature requests
and anything about golem
i'll be happy to talk about it with you
and you can also open
issues on the repo
so what's next the snow is way easier to
send
shiny into production
we've also opened a new website called
golemvest.org so
we are using this website to communicate
about golem but also all the other
package
that gravitates around golem so we have
another package called shinipsum we have
things like that that are
in the golden verse so everything around
golem will be listed
here
and finally we've been working on
this book called engineering production
grade shiny apps
which is about how to build a
shiny application for production so it's
not
a book for beginners it's more for
people who have already
a little bit of knowledge about shiny
and want to
go a step further so if you've heard
about mastering shiny by hadley
it's just like a book that comes after
that i'd say
and thank you
um all right we have time for a few
questions which i will uh
read off of the slide i o um all right
so our top question
is is golem the right fit for all shiny
apps
is there a rule for when a project is
big enough to need the framework
okay so you can build any shiny app with
golem so even
the small one i'd say that
i think it's easier to start with golem
for a small shiny app
than starting up then move to golem so
if you think that at some point your
shiny application might grow i think
it's easier to start with golem
start and if you already have the
template it's easier to continue and to
build a larger app
than to have the app and then
turn it into a column application
all right thanks uh our next question is
um
after this is one i'm very interested in
and hearing the answer to
uh after developing and working with
golem in production what have you
learned about shiny that you think
needs to be improved to make it even
better
a lot of things
maybe
that's a good that's a good one i'm very
looking forward for
working with asynchronous things in
shiny so the premises package
and i know the current implementation
is blocking for the user but i know joe
have been
providing some work around to use
promises and
i think this is something that i'm very
looking forward so a better integration
of
asynchronous programming in china
all right with our shiny server we have
problems with different shiny apps
requiring different package versions
how can golem help us solve this
in every golden package you will have a
description file containing
every description you need if you really
use
shiny server it will help you to install
this package
but i think you have to pro version to
have different
lip paths and so on to be sure to be
able to run
each shiny application in different
contexts
and golem will definitely help you to do
so
i think we have time for one more is
converting a shiny app into a package
necessary or crucial to be production
ready what is the main downside of
not having it as a package
the main downside is that if you provide
so if you think of it as a package
it contains everything needed so the
dependencies and everything so
you can bundle it into a tower bowl
and provide it to the it and it works
you don't have to provide them
the application and the requirements and
everything so
as it's in a package you can rely on
the package structure to to be tested
so we can use the tests we can use
the dependencies features and everything
that makes
our package strength so yeah
all right um thank you very much colin
and vincent
thanks thanks for talking
you